most people think selling is the gift of
the gab the ability to convince are any
ability to get across complex ideas
simplistically which salespeople are
losers they went into sat what forget no
one's in sales out of choice most people
at school when they're asked what do you
want to be would you grab maybe one in
every 10,000 to the South 99.9% of
people in sales fell into it they needed
a job and they ended up in the south and
they got stuck in about three or four
years and they realized I had no
transferable skill so then they just go
from sales job to sales job and what
happens is is most salesmen when I asked
the average MD be honest be really
honest do you have salesmen or do you
have order takers and they scratch their
head and they say I'd say I have order
takers because they work out that most
of their sales come from existing
customers who just give them orders most
sales they came to us they needed what
we had and we were able to prefer so
they placed orders and when you break
down the actual selling which is finding
people that didn't know they needed what
you have and then enabling them to
discover that you did they go no we
don't do that now that's selling
I'm joined by the UK's most hated sales
trainer
Benjamin Danny hey Benjamin welcome to
show thanks for having me Chris it's an
honor to be here
no we've got mutual friends and past
guests Mike win it you've been saying
about time with him recently right yeah
yeah I did I was up there last week
actually filming another episode
together having fun yeah he's a good man
he's great so why why you hated ye the
UK's most hated sales trainer why I get
asked that all the time if I gave a
speech on it last Thursday to a roomful
of businessman there's no international
standard by which this is measured have
you got a mug you must have a mug I'd
know not only I actually I do have a mug
okay you know that when someone gets
like number one dad mug yeah the
awarding body for the number one dad if
I can get it for you seeing as we were
mobile and I'm I'm in a hotel room for
anyone that wonders why that's and wigs
I'm up in London on business
Mike yes so product placement nice UK's
most hated sales trainer mug linking by
oh yeah so I created it I created the
character I was given some advice by a
very by a man who created his own brand
I'd have you ever heard of Brad Burton
no he's a UK's number one motivational
speaker and I asked him how did he
become number one and he said read my
book page 26
so I read his book page 26 and he said I
made it up and he got you by the book
and I thought well that's quite genius
and basically the rule to any I guess
I'm not not a marketing of a train
didn't never studied it but it's not
hard to realize that the easiest way to
get known is to create a message and
just keep hammering it like let's get
brexit done that was a classic you know
or take back control simple methods just
push it out over and over again so I
created the UK's most hated sales
trainer buy first of all what did nobody
want to be and I looked at LinkedIn and
everyone's number one of the best leader
professional guru Jedi
all self-aggrandizing BS well I thought
what does no one wanna be no one wants
to be hated and so I thought wow I'll go
with the UK so and then I thought it
makes no sense and I thought well that's
what makes it genius it makes no what
why would you be hated mm-hmm and then
it gave me carte blanche to just be
myself which is naturally quite blunt
and direct so that worked well and the
weirdest thing was standing up in a
meeting and introducing myself
I am the UK's most hated set of people
would look at you in fact what the hell
is this guy what why you haters no
reason I just yeah it's definitely an
openly but it's grown into something
quite what bigger than I thought it
would get and people constantly say it's
a great brand it's amazing what you've
come up with it's just brilliant how did
you think of it it literally is I just
create a space and own it I like it
while I'm itching down something that a
lot of people in business will get
advised to do right and I mean if you
create your own market you are by virtue
you are the market leader oh yeah I
think back to Mike's the UK's number one
D motivational speaker yeah who possibly
could come into my world and say no I'm
more hate yeah exactly
you think you are hate it's not a
competition you know that's great
okay so before we get into it I know
that this is what you spoke about with
Mike and if Mike puts that episode up
before this one goes the link to the
particular episode I'm talking about
will be in the show notes below for
anyone who's interested but wolf of
wallstreet real wolf of Wall Street
Jordan Belfort and Grant Cardone did a
podcast together about it's actually
three months ago now I don't know how it
slipped through my slip through my
little web of Internet stuff but for
anyone who hasn't seen it well actually
you've seen it right
well I being Mike wouldn't did a goggle
box and we filmed us watching it and
commenting on it we didn't watch the
whole thing so I must have watched maybe
a third of it but what I saw it was an
interesting dynamic how would you how
would you describe if he
haven't heard it it's two very I'd say
ego men put together in a room obviously
Jordan has set this up so you just
notice in the camera and the lighting he
looks much better you know full ring
from the the really start against poor
grad I grant his on the backfoot I would
say throughout most of the interview ah
and I think largely because when you
actually ask him specific questions he
can never give an actual answer he's a
lot like a politician you know there's
no substance behind what he's saying and
he gets caught out very very easily and
obviously Jordan is doing this on
purpose and Jordans obviously a smart
guy and so he's - he's just setting the
guy up to look stupid and I think that
was a whole point behind it for Jordan
as well I mean I say for the people who
haven't seen it Jordan Belfort is
verbally incredibly articulate and very
agile and he's a quick thinker where his
grunt appears to have a party line he
does sound like a politician he's not
that this is this is what he said before
and every so often it looks like it
looks like John Belfort skipping down
the road and grant every so often trips
over his own feet and finds something he
can rely on to say and then key a drill
in that and you are right I mean in
every internet review of that exchange
grant comes out as a real a real
Charlotte and I think a real Baghdad Lee
he because he's used to I think I'll it
might would it might wanna refers them
as a studio salesman as in he's a
showman and he gets up and he's used to
talking to audiences and when you're in
an audience it can't ask questions back
or challenge you and they just absorb
what you're saying
he removed that into the real world with
a guy that knows what he's talking about
and it's quite rude and he just fires
questions at you just like Andrew Neil
does with the politicians here in
England when you know he rips you apart
because they don't have any any specific
detail or you know and that's what
happened to her when you up onstage
you're always going to be an authority
right mmm exactly
but when you're reduced to just you and
a guy that knows more about you and has
got the question yeah it's tough Jordan
didn't set him up it was a bit cruel a
little bit yeah and then there's been
some after beef and stuff like that and
during the middle of it Grant Cardone
saying like we should do a MMA fight
charity fight you can see his egos
getting bruised and is such like alpha
posturing ad I really anyway for the
people that are more interested link
will be to that podcast plus when it
finally goes up yours and Mike's
gogglebox episode which I can't wait for
that will be linked in the show notes
below so you should totally go check it
out once you've finished listening to
this so we're good we're talking about
sales today right that's the currency
that you traffic in the slug in the mud
and the feces and the blood and all that
really bales and stuff yeah
so let's let's start absolute basics
what makes a good salesperson who it's
like what makes anybody a professional
and a professional as someone who's
mastered the basics has consistent habit
behavior and belief so it's all the
unsexy stuff actually a golfer Tiger
Woods is good because ain't he puppy he
had some natural aptitude let's not
fault that but he spent his life
practicing how to make every swing work
getting in the right mindset every
stroke is planned prepared
choreographed mapped out he knows what's
good and every shot he's in pieced
present he's not thinking about the last
shot he's not thinking about the next
shot he's in total control that is a
professional just like a top lawyer or
top surgeon they're in total control and
they've done that cut a thousand times
they've asked that question a thousand
times and they just know how when and
where to deliver it and where to cut and
so it looks like you're you've got an
amazing talent yeah I do but you know
how many times I've done this and then
is it it's it's learning to follow a
process and get good at it
that's all I got good at doing I just
read books and started doing stuff that
people said you should do to get good at
it rather than just read
like most people do and then stick it on
your shelf and take you just need to
think better all right I'll be more
positive today
that'll make me rich bollocks difficult
to repeat difficult to scale those
things yeah what are what are those
characteristics what are that what what
are the strategies are the the
particular approach is that someone
should have they've got as approach to
sales as you've said what what are the
things they should be drilling every day
Wow
prospecting every business sinks or
swims on your ability to generate leads
and I hate the word leads but basically
I want to talk to decision-makers in my
target market that may or may not have
problems I can fix now I don't know if
they have problems I can fix until I
phoned them and asked them now I've
chosen them because statistically they
fall into a category of person that
should doesn't mean they will so my job
is to consistently be speaking to people
that may need what I have diagnosing if
they do and if they do we figure out how
we move forwards or we figure out they
do need me but they can't afford me or
we figure out they do need me but they I
can't make a decision or the decisions
not there so it's all about prospecting
is that and prospecting bizarrely isn't
selling it's a different word prospect
it's a skillset in and of itself getting
in front of people as a skill then once
you're there you begin the sales process
and to me selling is all about
disqualifying not qualifying it's the
exact opposite and why do I say that
well put it this way there are more
reasons for person not to work with me
than there are to work with me there's
only a couple of reasons to work with
you but there's an entire universe of
reasons exactly so I'm gonna figure out
all the reasons why you can't work with
me and have you argue with me over why
I'm wrong and that's not a reason why we
can't and when I go through that process
it's completely reversed from what most
salespeople used to do it works because
the prospect does all the work they're
the ones arguing with me that no no no
no no we don't want to try outsourcing
our prospecting we don't want to hire
new people we don't want to fire people
we don't want to increase our prices
they've ruled out all the alternatives
and then what's left is me your product
my product and me
so yeah there are many ways to fix a
sales problem you don't need a sales
trainer put your prices up it's easy you
can open can't sell at that level right
so you can't put your prices up fire
your crappy sales we refer with those
people you say or there are many
alternatives and my job is to get them
to rule out all of them
and some people drop out on the way I
tell people I'm the nuclear option I'm
the last person you should get in your
to find out the final button you're
gonna have both the keys turn them at
the same time presidential exactly if
you're not ready to turn your key don't
get me in do you have many salespeople
so I can only imagine what it might be
like with you going in to an established
sales floor you've got this quite brash
got oh got you back mate that's right
it's a pre record anyway where are we -
11:50 here I can imagine when you go
onto a sales floor let's say that
company does decide to bring you in yeah
what's the atmosphere like because again
I've spent my total career of being an
adult at about nine nine months in sales
for a particular insurance company doing
outbound warm sales but during that time
even my small exposure there a lot of
posturing a lot of like so I've digged a
grant cardones of this world right the
alpha-male go get it environment so what
happens when you step in and you start
the same well I mean what do you say to
people family the first time I walk into
a building I get this look of disdain
people see me and I mean I bought 40 to
a slightly overweight I've longed here I
wear a cap I wear braces I look a bit of
a [ __ ] and I walk in and I get this
look and I get this look all the time is
this look of what this guy and that and
when I see that inside my head I think
got you yeah and so I'm used to people
giving me a look at contempt which is
the look I'm looking for because it
means part of the defense will starts to
drop so when I first get into a room and
I won't meet in the company because I'm
working with it but I got put the room
full of a lot of you two alpha males and
a very very very tough sale sort of
environment there I am and I'm sitting
in this room 8:00 in the morning I
couldn't even figure out how to turn the
lights on and I'm waiting for these
people to come up for the training and
their CEO had hired me and hadn't told
them that I was coming in he basically
just put in their calendar training and
so they start to trickle up one by one
and one of them recognizes me of into
this is now I recognize you you're the
guy from the YouTube video Yankees are
no no no one told us you were coming in
but anyway so I get 15 guys in the room
all alpha males and then there's me and
you could tell they all look bored they
didn't want to be there they're off the
phones five hours later though after the
first session I walked out with another
ongoing order with the guy singing my
praises saying it's unbelievable
and III only recently learned that the
CEO had put a plant in the training
because they built a very successful
business off the back of telephone
prospecting and basically his brief
Wiser's we're really good this guy
cannot be as good as what we are so find
the holes find out what just find the
flaws and that guy became the biggest
champion Stockholm Syndrome
Stockholm yeah bonded that is quite
common because people look at me and
again it's all choreographed I do
everything I do is deliberate and so I
want people to think that I want people
think this guy can't sell I want these
thing people to think this guy looks a
bit of a how would I learn from this guy
because what happens is is their
expectations are set that when I
challenge them and get them to realize
that I know
about their problem in a very non
aggressive non ego driven way they start
to move and yeah and that's that's why I
like it I love walking into a room and
getting that look of disdain because
then I think got one because if they're
all happy to see me then unarmed screwed
gonna be happy to see me yeah over so
we've talked about what you think makes
a good salesperson that is someone who
drills the basics who has a framework a
framework thick to they follow instant
consistency amyl prospects every day a
little bit often I'm not talking seven
hours straight but consistent
prospecting yeah very well okay so
that's what makes a good salesperson so
what are the common things you see that
make a bad salesperson because from my
experience I've of people that are in
all sorts of sales from normal telesales
on bottom end consumer products b2b b2c
IT staff recruitment and there's some
guys and girls who are in those
positions and I think you've got that
job because you're bit extroverted
you're a gobby shite and you've managed
to fall into a position that it looks
like you have the simulacrum of
competence what you have is the loudness
and brashness yeah that's very common so
yeah most people think selling is the
gift of the gab the ability to convince
any ability to get across complex ideas
simplistically most salespeople people
hate this but I said cuz I am one so I
can say most salespeople are losers
they went into sat what forget no one's
in sales out of choice these kind of
like last last ditch isn't it it's a the
the job that is always going to be
available even when the cockroaches are
the only thing that's left on this
planet after nuclear war it's still
gonna be a job for a sales particularly
so most people at school when they're
asked what do you want to be would you
grab maybe one in every 10,000 to the
South yeah so for those who watch this
who wanted to be a salesman at school
don't write me and say boy I wanted to I
get it
one
but 99.9% of people in sales fell into
it they needed a job and they ended up
in the south and they got stuck in about
three or four years and they realized I
had no transferable skill so then they
just go from sales job to sales job and
what happens is is most salesmen when I
asked the average MD be honest be really
honest do you have salesmen or do you
have order takers and they scratch their
head and they say I'd say I have order
takers because they work out that most
of their sales come from existing
customers who just give them orders yeah
most sales they came to us they needed
what we had and we were able to prefer
so they placed orders and when you break
down the actual selling which is finding
people that didn't know they needed what
you have and then enabling them to
discover that you did they go no we
don't do that now that's selling and
then I ask them to close their eyes and
listen to them on the phone and I say do
you hear grown-ups or do you hear a
little whimper kid or do you hear an
angry kid and they say I hate children
what do you mean if you listen to the
average sales person on the phone
they're very needy begging and pleading
ah sorry to disturb you it's now a good
time
that's a losery thing to say yeah you
just interrupted a busy person your
first thing to do is apologize for
wasting their time before you've even
wasted their time yeah and it's like
well you sound like a bit of a loser so
yeah so and you hear them begging people
and then they start arguing with people
so imagine being a doctor who
specializes in the flu and you phone
people up and you say people typically
have an appointment with me because they
have a runny nose they are they're
feeling lethargic and they've got a sore
throat and the guy says I don't have any
of those because yes you should this is
what sales people are like right and
they trick you with prospects and
because they saw because they said well
you must you must have these problems
and we're phoning you because we know
you're a company that should that's true
but maybe not right now just like
everyone will get the flu at some point
it doesn't mean the moment you call them
they recognize it
and so when you listen to them on the
phone they're very needy very big e very
pleading very subservient they're scared
to ask question and they spend most of
their time doing the talking because all
the plasma has to do is fire one
question so what is it that you do
and then they vomit on them well so
that's that's sort of linger on this
point for a second what what is the
power dynamic that you want to have is
it the complete reverse of that is it
halfway between the two so I spent my
life voting md's and CEOs I have to
sound and act like an MD or a CEO
because they that people by people like
them it's not people by people if people
bought people there would be no sales
problems would there you saw the most
likable person that you can put them on
phones and then that's like like them so
a garner Hawaiian shirt will sell to a
guy in a Hawaiian shirt okay a guy in a
Hawaiian shirt talking to the garden the
pinstripe suit in ain't going far very
quickly because they're two different
characters one will talk one way the
other the other so they don't they're
not like each other so when you phone up
an MD or a CEO you have to sound an act
like one and what are they selling like
the short sharp clipped Authority and
direct
if you don't sound like that when you
get through to me I instantly hear I'm
so sorry to disturb you and let me just
have 30 seconds to introduce my company
I think loser so what's the alternative
what's your approach my approach is just
blunt I said I'll be upfront missus
sales cool so you know hang up or let me
have 30 seconds what do you want to do
force them to make a choice and most say
I'll go on then what's it about I go
well if you don't like it we can end it
at 30 seconds fair fine and then I talk
about what I fix very Authority and if
he asked me a question well what is it
that you do Benjamin
well I fix problems like this you're
gonna tell me that doesn't interest you
right well how do you how do I fix it
will I'll be upfront with you sir that's
what you're gonna pay me a lot of money
to figure out right if I tell you that
now you won't need me no that's fair
so my question is do you recognize these
problems in your world yeah okay so few
more questions before I agree to meet
with you
powers shifted it so now I'm in control
I know that if you have problems I can
fix you should be grateful I phone you
it's a great way to put it another thing
is well like that I've got in my head is
that if there are any sales people that
are listening you are ringing people and
speaking to your prospects or your leads
whatever the terminology that you prefer
is you're speaking to them every day
this is for you
common trodden ground whereas like even
me who has had the same phone number
since he was at 14 so I'm on I'm on like
a bunch of different like cold call
lists and all the rest of it even for me
I only get one a week maybe or maybe one
every two weeks yeah so for me this
isn't this isn't my environment listen
where I'm supposed to feel comfortable
it's you you're supposed to take charge
don't get on the bus and then there's no
bus driver there to go yeah you gotta
drive it yourself or get into the
operating theater and you go well right
there you go that's the sutures and
that's the scalpel and you better open
yourself up and know you're gonna be
control I know what I fix it I'm damn
good at it so the question is do you
have problems and I need you to feel and
believe maybe this guy's got something
he simply sounds like he knows what he's
talking about and that's not blagging
and that's not not not gift of the
gabbing and it's not the crap you see on
the apprentice and all there you know in
the real world that doesn't work you can
badger someone into buying from you
don't get me wrong but these are the
people that then phone up a few days
later and said actually I've changed my
mind that's there's nothing successful
about it's almost like a lawyer winning
trials and then the jury comes they say
actually we changed our mind and we
don't go along with actually you were
wrong so yeah I mean that can't happen
it's a bit flippant but that's not
getting it and so it's not hard to steal
money from people it's not hard to lie
to people I mean all of these can be
done just because someone gives you
money doesn't make you a Salesman yeah a
Salesman I mean just because you
represent yourself in court a couple of
times doesn't make you a lawyer
yeah just good well let's plunder out of
your foot doesn't make you a surgeon
yeah so you
do things and maybe have some success
but it doesn't make you a professional
adder because a professional has
consistent outcomes and they're more
interested in how they get to where
they're going as opposed to whether or
not they get there that is the key thing
I don't care summer buys from me
what I care about is how I got to the
point where they made the decision they
weren't gonna buy from me because if
they should have bought from me and
they've decided not to it means I've
done something wrong which means I can
fix it mm-hmm whereas if we get all the
way and they buy I can say I know
exactly why they've bought as opposed to
I think it's cuz I like that yeah you
were saying to Mike that you you're able
to walk backward through your particular
sales pitch to most people yeah
everywhere every which way dissect it
however it needs to be dissected here's
the inflection point is the question
point at cetera yes if somebody if I was
to ask the average salesman talked me
through your last sales pull backwards
and they'd they'd struggle and I'd say
well this is it
I gave them one last reason not to meet
with me we then before that we agreed
what would happen by the end of that
meeting before that I asked them to
invite me in before that I finished on a
series of six questions which are
designed to move from intellect to
emotion before there I got permission to
ask those questions before their I asked
them did any of the three pains that I
suggested related before that I did my
30 second paying commercial before their
I did a patent interrupt to get
permission to do the circuit before that
I thought to myself before I picked up
the phone this guy's lucky I'm calling
him that's awesome there is its
structure and every call I make goes the
same way it never changes well again
with that so there'll be some online
marketers listening use of Anjani to
co-hosts of the show we'll be listening
as well and they they traffic in Grant
cardones world right they traffic in the
world of clickfunnels and of online
marketing and they actually now coach
coaches on line to start their own fit
Pro businesses but they want the bizarre
they actually want the same thing as you
so Johnny always says to me that the
single most painful sale
that he can make is one where someone's
typed in the URL of his website and then
gone through the process from there
because he has no idea where that person
has come from did they see
an advert online did they once watch a
and was it a blog post that then been
expanded out into an article and they've
seen somewhere
was it a referral was it a podcast was
it at this he said I need to be able to
track what's happened so that I can then
dissect it scale it retarget do all that
stuff and what you're talking about here
it sounds like is a verbal equivalent of
yeah right you want to be able to
process and structure i selling it on
the phone and face-to-face is the art of
human communication it's a communication
skill which means you have to have a
structure to that communication in order
to deserve which is designed to move a
prospect from a point to a point and in
any at any point along that journey they
can exit if it's not right for either of
us but if we get through it to the end
we're gonna work together and so I'm not
really a sales trainer I just teach
people how to communicate and I give
them a structure how to ask questions
how to nurture how not to ask questions
how wind knowing when to struggle the
art of deliberately struggling the art
of getting things wrong on purpose so my
job is to teach what a rookie did out of
ignorance a professional does on purpose
but deliberately and then we can scale
then we can wrap we can nail or we could
replicate and yeah that that's why I
like it it's theater yeah it definitely
is
and so I wanted to move up a level now
and I wanted to there will be a number
of people I know that are listening
because I'm going to send it to the
months we're done who are either
managers coaches or CEOs team leaders
within businesses that are doing sales
and I know that all of them have there's
there's a real a real unique atmosphere
between a team leader coach manager
whatever it might be and CEO and and the
guys on the sales floor and I think it's
a very very unique dynamic between them
wondered what you typically see in terms
of good and bad strengths and weaknesses
when you do see this relationship when
you go into businesses well often sales
managers are good sales people that got
promoted and the problem with that is
sales management skills are different
from being after sell so what happens is
you often lose a good sales were to get
a shitty manager that's quite a lot a
lot of times CEOs and business owners
they slightly lost touch with their
sales team because they've extricated
themselves from the sales but they know
how to do sales and so most most MDS and
CEOs are get in front of they often say
to me you know what painter I just wish
my guys were like me when I set up this
business I was out there bang bang bang
and I said look that's why you owned the
business and they work for because if
they would genuinely like that do you
think maybe here working for you yeah
well no they wouldn't no no we have to
appreciate that most of the end the good
once of what we need to do is find the
ones that we can invest and coaching is
about the getting best at him so a sales
manager has two roles hire the best
people and get the best out of them
that's it one of the biggest problems is
most sales managers and most companies
have their own styles targets the
problem is you've got actually now where
do you think we gonna spend most of
their energy and effort in hitting this
sales target so they spend more time
focusing on the thing they shouldn't be
focused on so sales managers should not
have a sales target he should be
targeted on what all his guys do so his
job is to get the best out of them to
monitor their minimum behaviors to hold
people accountable to challenge them and
ask questions not to accept excuses you
know and they accept excuses left right
and center don't accept excuses they
need to give their people structure so
that they can hold them to it the big
problem with salespeople is we like to
leave them to their own devices and
that's what salesmen love that it's a
badge of honor you know I need a process
I'm alright with us I you know I've done
a million ease meetings I just go and
people buy people they like me and I'm
gonna pursue
that's like mention asking your lawyer
why are you so good naturally warden to
be hiring you and any you ask your
professional because I'll tell you why
it's because I do this every single time
in this I challenge I challenge us this
this this I know where I'm going I have
a sir same with a surgeon why do your
patients not does sales would love their
you know cuz if you ask the average
salesman why did we win that order and
they say I don't know doesn't matter
we've won in a certain course of [ __ ]
madness because if we know how to do it
again we can repeat it loose it's never
their fault now they did not want any
brexit it's like it could be you man
that's not because I sold last week with
your unscalable and repeatable sales
process there's nothing nothing about
that that's good there will only get you
so far don't don't get me wrong you can
make a lot of money doing it that way
and most most sales would do but it's
very frustrating and it doesn't improve
you as an individual or give you better
skills and I I think I I'm a nurse just
to get better at what I do the money
comes it's a byproduct of doing
something well it successful people tell
you that money is never the end goal it
happens to be a byproduct of doing
something well I agree so two things
I've got two doors to he'll open in my
mind at the moment the first one is if
you don't promote the people that are
good at selling to be the people who
lead the sellers why do the people that
are sellers respect their team leader if
they haven't come up through the selling
process let's say that we have some
alternative arrangement whereby it's not
the best seller who's been there for a
while that then becomes team leader we
get so many news a particularly good
manager but maybe not amazing it's
selling or else you just have them as a
salesperson right what's the saloon
- that there because you need to have
that respect from the guys on the floor
this is true it's a good question
learning management skills I've just
said it there it is a skill which can be
learned so you'd need to invest in
upskilling people to remind you're no
longer a Salesman now and the key thing
that you need to focus on is getting the
best out of your people so if you ask
and this is would be a good testers you
need to ask your top salesman who you
want to promote why are you such a good
salesman what is it that you do can you
can you distill it can you can you
systemize it are you able to repeat it
or is it what most salesmen say it's
just I just have unique it's just my
ability it's just just what I do
so no you see if you can't distill that
yourself you're never gonna be able to
pass it on do you need so you need to do
some academic understanding of why
you're good at what you do so a lawyer
can become a law lecturer there and most
lawyers heping lecturers or most
lecturers have been lawyers at some
point and practice at law because they
can do what they teach but they also
understand why what they do works that
is that I think is fundamentally like
and gives you feel feel free if you ask
average sales person it doesn't matter
how many years I'm in sales
why do people buy what's the process a
human being goes through to buy most
people look at me blankly they don't
know that's that's the that is the thing
that's the answer why do people buy what
again what what's the process they go
through and they look at you and most
people then have some idea they say well
they've they buy out a need no yes they
do
no no no what I know but that that's
that's not the answer what is the
process they go through where how does a
human being by and they look at you
blankly in there i I don't know they
make a wolf they buy emotionally
are we getting near of what else I don't
I don't know so you've been in sales for
five years and you don't know this they
feel like asking a lawyer who's been
practicing for five years how does the
High Court
I think the guy on the wig at the top
makes our decisions you know into it if
you don't understand the basics and this
is it because people don't believe
selling is a profession or or actually a
skill they call themselves professionals
and they say selling czar skill but when
you ask them can you quantify and tell
me why you're good at what you do they
look at you blankly and I don't really
know well then the hell are you all
about I suppose as well that that means
that the worst person that you could
promote from salesperson to team leader
would be the naturally talented person
who's maybe not too self analytical and
has a passion for sales yes because
you've muted their passion for the one
thing that they enjoyed doing and they
have absolutely no idea why they have
success as that particular thing yeah
conversely I'm gonna guess probably why
a lot of team leaders will be made team
leaders he's just so passionate about
sales and it's just got he's got a
natural gift it's like yep [ __ ] leave
him there yeah I don't take him out of
that role well this is it but we live in
a world which constantly bangs on about
you know work on your weaknesses the
school system is terrible for that see
you remember at school you get your
school report and it would say does
really well of math does alright in
English but his geographer he needs to
try harder and it's like why are we
gonna do with geography
what I should say is he's bloody good at
math and he should really spend more
time doing bad yeah he's interesting the
fact that we we go from this sort of
shallow and broad to narrow and deep and
you know anyone who's read James clears
atomic habits from this year knows that
you cannot be the best in your field at
everything you need to pick your battle
then you need to try and win it over and
over and over and over and over again
and there is this some point there's
some like weird age it's like 18 and a
half or something and you hit eighteen
and a half and everyone on the planet is
like right we don't care about how broad
your skillset is we just want you to be
brilliant at one thing
and that it's all about how good you are
at that one thing but you're right
before that it's you do you need to
cover this incredibly broad range of
subjects you don't you've got you
haven't got statistical brain or you
just love sport you know these guys that
love love sport throughout school and a
force to study all that time you think
how much better can I be if I was
playing sport the air school that's it
so don't work on your weaknesses you
work on your strengths and you find
someone who has strengths and your
weaknesses and you buddy up that's how
businesses work you know this is why the
MDM EFT is so different one's good with
numbers one's not good I mean money ones
job is to stop and spending money ones
blue sky think of one's a bean counter
but they complement each other and
that's how they work and it's just like
you know marriage opposite you see you
see it's a how did she get with them
it's one of those things you know but
it's cuz it's so different to each other
that they complement each other with
their different personality traits you
know you always get a really thin guy
with a large woman or you know it's odd
they do so and that's that's what it's
like answer find out what you're good at
and just get good at doing it don't
don't worry about trying to be a
jack-of-all-trades got you so that was
the first door to hell second door to
hell will close this one now you know is
if there is a problem with the process
is that not the issue with the company
rather than with the salesperson should
the company not have either more
stringent sales processes that people
need to go through like well most sales
people
most companies confuse sales process for
the structure they follow and by that
when you say what's your sales process
to go well we have a first meeting then
we do a proposal they would go to pitch
and then we'll one and then we'll map
out that's their SUP but that's not a
sales process that's a structure you
seem to get trapped into every time you
meet a prospect though I'm saying when
you get in front of a prospect what's
the game plan when you walk in there do
you know how you're going to move that
person from intellect to emotion them
back to until it because that's how
they're gonna buy because first of all
it's going to be all intellectual
they're not going to tell you the truth
or open up to you
so what's your game plan for getting the
CEO of that company to open up to you
about the real reason why you're sitting
in front of them ah well we just tend to
go on and talk about what we do yeah
okay so that's not really a process i
selling is a communication that i need
to get a human being i know he buys
emotionally so how do i get that guy
emotionally to open up to me about why I
am there
very hard to do if you don't know how to
do it it's not coming and vomit features
and benefit so it's is it a company's
fault yes cuz most companies don't know
how to sell most companies sell all and
I know and I again when people see what
I teach I point out that most the buyers
created a system whereby they're always
in control and every now and then they
let salesmen would and don't realize it
and they think they're selling but what
they're really doing is taking an order
cuz the buyer has actually already
decided I wanted to work with you guys
I've just put you through your paces but
I was always gonna buy now they'll never
tell you this they'll give you some
cock-and-bull story about how oh you
know we just felt it was a certain blood
but no I knew from the very beginning we
were gonna work with you but I didn't
tell you that so most buyers you know
they they they are willing that they're
ready to place an order most salespeople
go when they do the dog-and-pony show
give the intellectual justification of
the prospects is alright of it and I
think [ __ ] we're good they'd already
decided to buy before you got there you
just gave the intellectual justification
for them to exercise their emotional
decision no no no no no it's down to me
lose that other deal where you did
exactly the same thing oh wow you don't
just wrong target so you've touched on
the question I wanted to ask and I don't
know whether this is the one what that
I'm gonna have to crowdsource a lot of
people to pay you money for but why do
people buy why does a customer buy well
again people buy emotionally justified
intellectually so in order for someone
to give you money they have to feel it
so thing
about this um the toothpaste you have in
your bathroom you've either got a tube
or a pump tube
you got a tube I got a pump why if it
thought about it why are you I don't
think I don't think I like the punk baby
I don't like the pump utterly irrational
yeah yeah every morning you brush your
teeth and the last thing you want to do
is be bitching about the device which
dispenses your toothpaste so you buy
toothpaste emotionally it's because I
buy the pub because I which by the way
is the least emotional product that I am
thinking it's emotionally driven
I hate mint so I buy plain I don't like
the stripes because I hate stripes so I
get the other one you know and it's all
of it as a rationale but when you're in
the supermarket making a decision you
buy the one that makes you feel the best
so every purchase is emotionally driven
so British Telecom knows that to get you
to pick up the phone right and call your
mum on this weekend to pay no more than
1 P for the whole call is intellectually
dry how do you get people to act on that
you can't so they may hire an
advertising agency you may create an
advert and then this advert it's a
little old lady she's sitting in a chair
the camera slowly pans around she's got
a bun in her hair she's knitting away
it's very soft focus and then the voice
this is have you talked to your mother
lately and you think [ __ ] no hook you
with guilt that's a feeling and then
they say oh by the way caller this
weekend to pay no more than 1 P so every
advert is designed to hook your motion
ly to get you engaged with it selling is
the same when you get in front of the
CEO or the bar of whatever your product
is and they say we're very interested in
your new software you don't talk about
the software it's that what why do you
need the software because we're having
problems or how big other problems what
are you done to fix it what's the impact
on the business how does it make you
feel knowing that all this is happening
and you soon discover they're buying not
because they care about you or your
product but if you can fix this for me
you're gonna
a lot of grief in my life that's what I
want the software for it's got nothing
to do with the the certification or the
the widgets or anything it's if it can
fix this if we could get my boss off my
back who every bloody Monday's bitching
at me I will pay double yeah so that's
the business were in so people buy
emotionally may justify intellectually
our job as a salesman is to find out
what is the compelling emotional reason
why do you need to do this sir and if
you don't how does that make you feel
and if the answers I don't really care
it doesn't bother me
they're never gonna spend money mmm that
was a put that that was a point there
that grant and Jordan had a real
back-and-forth about yeah I think Jordan
Belfort was adamant there are buyers and
there are non buyers Grant Cardone was
there are only buy as everybody wants to
buy something and his argument was I
need a wide enough product range so that
when I need to speak someone speak to
someone they can buy anything which was
then framed by Jordan in a really
unethical but I think in a way that made
grant look like a complete dick yeah
yeah theatre what if they're not buying
fish
well they are but no no that no grunt
they are not buying fish this person has
said they don't want fit while they are
and that was it for two and half hours
here so exactly I mean Jordan is is
right but it goes back to I that's why I
prefer the doctor analogy because it's
more accurate everybody at some point is
going to get the flu and every at some
point therefore is going to have
symptoms that indicate they may have the
flu so my job is to look for people that
have the symptoms because actually some
flu symptoms are also in flu symptoms
that could be cancer so it turns out
what I get there and I diagnose is that
actually you don't need a flu specialist
you need an oncologist and I don't sell
oncology services so what happens is
just because somebody has symptoms of a
problem you can fix there's a jaw I
think Krantz approach is if someone has
a septum I'll give them a product if I'm
not an oncologist I'll tell them a
cancer solution yeah yeah well I can see
the point to that but then you're the
jack of all master of none whereas
Jordan saying we'll know some people
will need what
you have in a particular moment in time
in others won't the guy doesn't want
fish he ain't gonna buy fish but in
three weeks he may want fish mm-hmm you
need to be top of the list of people to
call when the fish yeah hunger strikes
oh yeah this is why we've developed
prospecting profiles our profile our
ideal prospect is a company in this
sector turning over this who probably
buys this sort of equipment so that's my
profile but I don't know at any given
point in time when that particular
prospect than that profile will need
what I have that's why I prospect so I'm
talking to them and at some point they
say you called at the right time engine
but I do have all of those issues
I didn't six weeks ago when your call
this is why you phoned someone up and
they say ah we've literally just bought
that solution yeah ah you should have
called earlier well I'd be trying to be
trying you for years well well that's
how it works you got a call at the time
when they have symptoms if they don't
have symptoms they're not gonna talk
simple as that it's very easy selling
and that's why that's why salespeople
are so frustrated because they spend
their whole life trying to argue with
people why they should be buying from
them as soon as someone says no I'd do
one last question fire out one thing to
see if they're if it's a real no or if
it's a failure and they don't move on to
the next prospect and that's exactly
what Jordan says I'd rather talk to the
person who's likely to say yes then have
an argument with the guy who's told me
no in the hope that I could browbeat him
into saying yes that's not selling I
imagine as well so my my brief stint
doing upsells to an existing motoring
product up here in Newcastle I struggled
to remove myself from being emotionally
invested the outcome of the sale so I
would if I had a good day I would feel
good if I had a bad day I would feel bad
yeah I'm gonna guess that's pretty
common very common you've got to
separate your role from your identity so
you a Salesman as a role it's just a
function that you perform
you're a Salesman when you go into the
office
but when you walk out your your uh I
don't know if you're married or have
kids but you're a father a brother a
husband a son those are also roles and
so what people do is they allow Robley
so you you and you allow your behavior
in your role to bleed into how you see
yourself as a human being as a person so
I had a [ __ ] day as a Salesman ergo I'm
probably a pretty crap person so I feel
bad about myself whereas you gotta
actually know do you think your lawyer
burst into tears at the end of a trial
cuz he loses it I hope not
no he takes office where he goes well
you know you win some you lose some
we did everything right we always knew
it was gonna be tough we always said the
outcome could go either way it went the
way we didn't want to go back the way it
rolls I'm not a shitty person because I
didn't win I don't feel bad I haven't
had a bad day at the office I may be
slightly annoyed cuz I hate I did want
to win but when I look at everything we
did we did everything right
so wasn't good that comes back to
controllables versus uncontrollables
right yeah you can't you can't control
whether or not that person is ready to
buy at that time know if they're not
ready to buy at that time you were never
ever going to sell to them all you
control is everything up to the point
they have to put their hand in their
wallet which is a lot yeah yeah and my
job is to get them to the point that
they want to stick their hand into their
wallet if I've got to the point and it
comes to them sticking their hand into
the wallet and they're not willing me
put it in there I've screwed up earlier
on I should have got out earlier so
that's why it comes down to how you
disqualify do you ever find yourself
listening I don't know whether you've
got some special agreement with UK wide
sales companies where they they do not
get your number but I don't know whether
you ever receive cold calls or whether
you receive sales oh I do yeah do do do
you find yourself allowing my laying the
role of a customer just to sort of
listen to them and assess you have a dev
use it as a little case study for
yourself what can't you just [ __ ]
sick of sales and you just you you want
to get off it I listen to them and I
humor them go
behave like a prospectus I can't file up
being a prospect so I can behave how a
lot but this is a true story i am i
think was last year know at the year
before the year before i know last year
was last anyway anyway last year so i
was making some prospecting calls and my
signal kept cutting in and out down to
calls talking to a managing director the
phone line just pissed off so i was
annoyed
so we're here that afternoon i my phone
rang and I answered it there was some
guy selling telecoms now normally you
tell them to you know if I'm not
interested but III I said no no no no
here and the guy was alright he asked
some good questions and I quite liked
what he was doing and I said you know
what I said I'm in let's do it because
really you wanna I said yeah I guess
okay I move before I go can I ask you a
question though before we move on I said
do you know why buying from you and he
said well yeah because some you were
saying well because we're giving you an
extra 10 Meg's of data you can unlimited
it all of us
I say it's got none of that because I
see I tell you what this morning two
calls of mine screwed up I pissed off at
o2 I have no idea if you're gonna
provide a better service at this point I
don't care all I know is is that they're
not gonna be getting my money from today
I'm buying out of spite and out a
fallacious vengeful it's got another
emerges I see I don't need ten MiG's IV
the youth ten MiG's in a month in my
life and you offered me a discount
before I even asked I've gotta take it
but you were too quick I see you giving
me a great deal but it's none of that is
why I'm changing I only listen to you
because I was pissed off I was
emotionally annoyed you got me at the
right time and then just if I didn't
lately he gave me the reason all right
fine Amin let's do it yeah that is it so
this is why doctor know what to say how
and you can you can create that feeling
though so it's important what you say on
the phone I'm very bigoted you don't
talk about what you do
talk about what you fix see you identify
the three biggest symptoms that your
prospects are likely to suffer from and
ask them do you have them because they
may say actually I do know that I'm
thinking about dude yeah I have noticed
that now we're gonna have a conversation
so that's my job it's just I know what I
fix and I know what it looks like in
your world you don't know what I fix but
you do know what the symptoms in your
world look like all I've got to get you
to admit as you have one some are all of
those symptoms and we're gonna have a
chat about how it can help if you don't
recognize any of it I'll call you back
in three months because at some point
you will these symptoms are going to
metastasize into a full-blown illness
exactly yeah
so I know that you mentioned that you've
done some live sales calls before where
you actually essentially don't know the
product where you've gone into yes
companies and sold whatever it is not
knowing it and I suppose that that is
okay what is it fix what do you what
what is a managing director in your
target market bitching about that you
fix but he doesn't know you're the
solution so I do I work with a company
that sells valves and we had to go
through this process and I said bar they
and there are constantly annoyed at
price increases in this product range
okay okay what else annoys them
sometimes they have problems with with
with cladding it's very specific and so
the water gets in there can be
frustrating what else ah and another one
is I suppose if you order these things
it can be leaked um if you've got a
project and you can't get them in quick
enough it can ever knock out I go fine
right that's all I need to know right
let's make some sales calls so they
don't just phone up engineering
directors and I said I'll be upfront
it's a sales call you can hang up no no
it's fine what'd he say so look I get
invited in by engineering directors
they're often in the oil industry such
as yourself and I'll be honest they're
probably already using a certain valve
but some of them complained that
sometimes I have water ingress issues
and as a result the valve is leaking
others say their biggest concern is at
that but sometimes lead
times can be challenging and if they
don't get a part that can have a knocker
and a few tell me that their biggest
concern is and I can't remember what the
third one was I say that I go but I get
the feeling you're gonna tell me you
don't recognize any of that and it's
amazing they all go well no no no no no
no no I recognize that we we do suffer
from there I okay well off those three
things water leaking into it
a lead time or whatever the third one
was if you can pick one of those to fix
which would you pick I'd say it's the
water okay I've had my 30 seconds can I
speak to you for a maybe two more
minutes yes sure so when you say the
water ingress what do you mean exactly
and then they start talking to me about
their problem they don't realize it it's
all I got to do it doesn't matter what I
sell it's what do I fix how does what I
fix manifest itself and my prospects
world how do I talk to them about that
so suppose thinking about it in that
sort of a way you are very much a Swiss
Army knife
as someone who has selling ability and
you need what a week's training probably
on even the most complex of of products
half a day hour to figure out what
people thinks it's funny because most
people don't and it's funny and every
company I go into a new ass what are you
fix what do you fix how does a man and
they look at you blankly and it takes
ages and it isn't as fascinating you
spend older if your life phoning up
people telling them you know them you
understand them you live and breathe
their world and you can't tell me what
you think I said that's shameful isn't
it
imagine your doctor not being able to
well there's people sometimes these
people come in yes and well sometimes
they're not very well yes and [ __ ] you
know I drawing a lot a horse - well yeah
Gillis so this is what my job is I how I
get people to discover I get to the
figure and I teach them how to say it
cuz it's all theater it's all acting and
everything that I say is choreographed
you've got to serve in the right way
you're going to ask the question anyway
you've got to pause at the
right moment for effect as my job is to
create emotion it's acting what's the
difference between a good actor and a
great actor it's not the script it's the
delivery of the script yeah a great
actor takes the script and turns it into
something but he doesn't have to alter
the words he just delivers it pauses in
the right place emphasizes the right
thing that's my job on the phone in in
person it's all choreographed to make
the prospect feel okay about themselves
and comfortable and open up to me when
you say it like that thinking about the
power that a salesperson has someone
with a real sales talent sales people
must be good properly good scalable
replicable framework based salespeople
must be some of the most valuable
workers on the planet yes the whole
world is capitalist it's buying and
selling that's it
our world turns on there so selling a
lot of sales jobs will be replaced by AI
a lot of these phone based ones because
all they're doing up is taking orders
and you can teach it an algorithm I've
listened to these Google AI things and
I've heard one make a phone call and
make an appointment and you wouldn't
know you're not talking to a person so
all you've got to do is program a
computer who has no emotion has no
feelings and only will follow an
algorithm and do the same thing well
over and over again before long most
sales people you won't leave them and
this is my biggest fear is a lot of
salespeople don't realize they're not
going to be required unless they have
that skill themselves like the
algorithmic or gonna still be doing the
face-to-face higher level though they
are under threat Wow
so people need to up their skills yeah
without doubt well Benjamin it sir
there's been absolutely amazing if
people want to find out a little bit
more where should they head to what can
they like and they get you well LinkedIn
is the best place to find me so if you
just put in UK's most hated sales trade
or binge of a dead heat my website
funnily enough is UK's most hated sales
trader.com
but it's it's nothing sexy it literally
is a brochure desired to take card
payments eventually yet people say your
website shut I go well you're not hiring
a web designer so what's why are we
having this conversation that's a great
point yeah I'm not a web design I built
it myself
congratulations yes it was easier crap I
saw a example in behavioral economics
today from Richard chaton who is the
author of the choice Factory in a
previous modern wisdom guest and this
example said outside of a butcher's shop
he said sausages inside 10 pounds but
sausages had too many apostrophes in it
he said the number of people that walk
into the shop and said you know um you
know the sign outside has like two
apostrophes in sausages and essentially
doesn't need any he says yeah I do
now how many sausages do you want yeah
it's brilliant little bit I love it I
love that open loop you've gotta get it
man yeah so anyway everything that we've
spoken about today Benjamin's website is
fantastic LinkedIn where he keeps on
putting up great content and this
Twitter which I've got a YouTube channel
YouTube and if you grab you could would
a mug or a teacher or a cat fantastic
make sales great again like salesmen
great again wait makes salesman great
again architects deliberately do I wind
up the woke folk of today you do indeed
that doesn't surprise me at all also
you're gonna have at some point in the
future might be having a digital product
coming out which yeah
touchwood it'll launch in January it's
an online training platform so a lot of
people can't get to me here in the UK to
come to my event but they'd love to do
some online training so I've filmed
these events and I've chopped it all up
and turned it into a training portal
which people can buy a subscription to
so that'll be I don't know all the
specifics yet but it should be next
month but it'll be on LinkedIn and
marketed through LinkedIn so perfect I
love it man Benjamin thank you so much
for your time I appreciate it thanks for
having me on
[Music]